-Hey!
-Hi, Jimmy.
-Oh, thank you so much
for doing our show.
I appreciate it.
You know, I'm the biggest fan of
"Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants,"
so I have to talk about it.
And I know I'm not
your audience,
but I loved it so much.
I know you guys are actually
pretty close in real life.
Right?
-We are. We totally are.
-I've seen photos of you guys
out. I'm like, "What?"
Like, I would probably freak o--
I might cry
if I ever saw the whole --
you guys all together.
-[ Laughs ] Well, let's make
that happen, Jimmy.
I want to see you cry.
-No, don't make me cry.
But I do love you guys.
-Well, there was one time
where -- well, they surprised me
with a bachelorette party
that I didn't want.
But they took me to
a restaurant, and, of course,
at each of our place was, like,
a pair of jeans
and arts and crafts.
So that night, like,
restaurant-goers were treated to
watching "The Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants" decorate jeans.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
-Then the liquor came,
and then it got more exciting.
-[ Laughs ]
-People got to watch us decorate
jeans inside of a restaurant.
-What a good group.
Hey, America, I want to talk
to you about -- we're five days
from Election Day,
and I just want to thank you.
You're doing so much great work
to help encourage people
to vote
and keeping people informed.
I follow you on Instagram
and all the socials.
But you do a thing
called America AF
where you answer
simple questions about voting.
It's safe to watch-ish.
It's bleeped.
-[ Laughs ]
-What made you start doing this?
-Well, you know, back in 2018
when we were trying to
get people out
for the midterm elections,
I realized that, like,
a lot of people didn't even know
what the midterm elections
were or, like, what the point
of the midterm elections are.
Why they're important,
why they matter.
And I realized I had this tool
to just, like, speak directly to
at least the people
who followed me
on social media and tell them.
And so I just started
trying to explain things,
and I remember asking people
like, "Why aren't you voting?
Like, just tell me.
I need to know. Like, why?"
And, you know, I'm expecting
these big ideological, you know,
reasons of like,
you know, "The system's rigged.
Nothing's ever going to change."
And then the responses
were like,
"I don't have a car
to get to the polls."
Like, "I don't know
what I.D. I need."
"I don't know where to go
to get registered."
"No one's ever asked me --"
Like, all of these
super-simple problems
to solve with information,
with resources,
and I thought, you know,
"I'm going to do what I can do
with my platform to give
information to the people
who are following me."
It feels like the thing
people come up against the most
is like,
"Does it really even matter?
Does my vote matter?"
You know, and I was lucky enough
to speak to this, like,
superhero election law attorney.
Again, like, I'm a big nerd.
Like, that's what
gets me excited.
I get to speak to, like,
an election law attorney,
Marc Elias, and, you know,
I asked him like,
"Does every vote matter?"
And he just said,
"Oh, my God, does it matter."
Like, in 2018, we lost
a Senate race in Florida
by one tenth of 1%.
Do you know what would be
happening right now
if there was another Democrat
in the Senate?
So one of the things people have
to remember is that, you know,
we're not just voting for
the president.
You're voting for
senators and congressmen
and district attorneys
and sheriffs,
people who make such a massive
impact in your community
and arguably have just as much
if not more impact
than the president.
So showing up and voting
in those local races
often comes down to
just tens of votes.
And so it so matters
that we show up.
-I want to talk about your new
initiative called She Se Puede.
-Good pronunciation, I love it.
-Not bad? Thank you.
-Not bad.
-I appreciate that.
Can you explain how this started
and what it is?
-Yeah. She Se Puede is a new
online platform that I launched
with my dear friend Eva Longoria
and also a number of
other amazing Latinas
across business and politics
and organizing and activism.
And it's a new lifestyle
platform for Latinas.
It's a place for us to be
celebrated and to be empowered
in everything from, you know,
raising children, cooking meals,
our workouts,
asking for a raise,
and also our engagement
civically.
I mean, the numbers of Latinas
are so often spoken about
in this country.
But numbers don't equal power.
Power equals power.
And in order for us
to really make a difference
and to be reflected and
represented in this country,
we need to be empowered to use
our -- use the power
of our numbers to change the way
politics happen in this country,
to change the way
our communities are treated.
And so the civic-action piece is
a really big part of
She Se Puede.
But it's really about
celebrating and reflecting
every aspect of our lives.
-Yeah, good for you.
I want to talk about
"Superstore"
because Season 6
premiered tonight.
And next week is
your character's final episode.
-That's right, yeah.
-You were about to
film this episode in March,
and then the pandemic hit, so
you came back again this season.
And you had to
basically say goodbye
to everyone
twice or three times?
-Yeah, I had, like, my final
table read three times.
And it was --
it was just a mess.
I mean, I, like, sobbed
like a baby the first time.
-Of course.
-I couldn't even get words out.
And then the second time,
I didn't know it was going to
be my last table read,
and then --
so when the final day finally
came, I had nothing to give.
I had, like, cried
all the tears.
I said goodbye.
-"Yeah, I'm exhausted.
You know I love you."
-Yeah.
-But I'm happy that
you got to come back
and finish it the right way.
-Totally.
And I -- You know, I did
100 episodes of the show.
I love the show.
I'm so glad that it's going on
and that the fans are going to
continue to watch it
and love it.
And I'm always going to be a fan
of the show.
And it was such an amazing
five years of my career,
and I'm always going to be
grateful for it.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's America Ferrera
in "Superstore." Take a look.
-And Zephra is adamant that we
follow the CDC recommendation of
washing your hands
for a full 20 seconds.
-20 seconds?
That's like literally forever.
-It's about the length of
two "Happy Birthdays."
So just sing that
and you'll be fine.
-Yeah, but whose name
do we insert?
I have a friend named Ty
and I have a friend named
Alexandria Genevieve.
Those are two wildly
different timeframes.
-Just say the name Emma.
-Oh, God.
Is this your way of making us
sing "Happy Birthday"
to Emma because all of
her friends ditched her
on her birthday this year?
-No, that didn't happen.
Emma is very popular,
and she's dating a very cute boy
name Braden.
Very cute.
I don't mean cute
like I think he's hot
because I'm an adult
and that would be weird.
Whatever. Just wash your hands.
There's a virus.
-America Ferrera.
"Superstore" airs Thursday
nights at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.
And make sure you check out
shesepuede.org.